for our little event over there because
we we had Washington come down and to
sort he plays here Smith supermarket and
he had very clearly designed objectives
courses as well when certain things
happen that were like clearly hot metal
hard counter certain things that will
come up and I so I'm just wondering like
is that like a comment
Yoshio treatises as well match up
knowledge or is that just something that
Toussaint designed itself kind of deal
we're here we are we are getting the
MENA selection again you got to keep it
rockin you know what he it's kind of a
hot streak with her
why not rock it out also he just had the
potential though if he even if he
doesn't lose a few games just switch it
up to other characters if he chooses to
but here we go we're gonna get our game
1b DG's blue god versus low loving and
this is the losers finals three out of
five right here winner of this is going
to be moving on to grand finals first
game hello girl oh my god Rd that one's
guard gave me chomp else we'll just that
wasn't move he's G item like four time
oh my god red it's red
oh goodness and I believe this is a ring
I thought I thought he could do the
little sideline cuz I understand I
understand either way you got the
guaranteed follow up at the guard break
though really don't need to a lot of
people run into that move not knowing
what it actually
you punish that very very long so charts
coming out a little it makes that I mean
he's got it back to the left so I can
totally understand why he was gonna
charge here right someone hash take
energy right now right now I guess it
ended up not mattering is all of it
still gonna be able to pick the round
right now he's currently up to and very
very quickly get the one-eighth right
now trying to floss axes okay good look
at the card damaging Oh every time to
dig on the board with the perfect he
also can burn any of his videos except
it gets late touch of the side oh it
gets me to the tip there no [ __ ] at the
eye as well she's gonna be never LEDs
yeah boom is it there's the auto GI on
it big damage that's gonna do it now
we're just as quick as Lolo took the two
rounds we come right back at you that
move has been nerfed a pretty pretty
hardcore of fat and you can just use it
as like walk separate very very
hardly catches anything the puffle is
actually gonna catch some max rage right
now he jumps over the muscle buster but
no fear from blue body this is five
eight soldiers right now but does not
matter though the gods run up our car
you go take a game one yeah you laughing
at all you know that's the kind of thing
that happens you have to be able to
laugh that off otherwise you get upset
and then it just gets in your head right
I love it right in the back right away
just take over like garbage damage but
not today blue god taken a massive
sidestep great job for him it was under
situations 570 this time get that lethal
for it oh my goodness
closer yeah yeah now you're packing up
he's like I have all for half a life
lead and I do not want to get reversed
or now
it just feels so one-sided right now
indices yeah blue bags stuff in your
mouth close was like having conversation
like whoa whoa stop that's my bust up my
guard eat like this I learned from the
first game okay
we're good now stop and let loose nah
keep it oh yeah it definitely feels like
we got that that last round is like you
doing the boy out of told you yeah I
know Lola makes responding right back
right this is you IO on the joke oh yeah
he was very careful he was watching so
and there it is
hey I got one stick of butter to work
with
lo-lo's guard gates like a mighty thin
yeah I mean it may be best to honestly
just take a guard break right now on
beating what's gonna call me if you get
the guards break later could be like oh
oh oh nice block akin on the muscle
buster in a full 25 it attendants not
tucking right there to fall into the
lethal in a trap it's just barely upside
arranging yah he's just kind of trying
to be nice and patient now I'll punish
on that and Lola will however get some
big punish on that put you up let's go
live through this don't forget who you
just have me to burn as well he chooses
to
for Humanity all right here we go all
right we gonna go yeah that's air
control okay but just like that he had a
beautiful sighs that as a scream said
that was courage yeah I think it you
notice it around the midway point of
that match he started going to sidestep
a lot lot more pretty much a sidestep
sidestep okay right barks your pillow
and you notice that Lolo is now using
horizontal because of how many touching
that stops and sigdi coming out put them
in in distorts answer very hard to fight
with sword stance he's just so fast I
just walk though in the mid the muscle
buster ends up coming out however again
guards below low yeah so he backs off he
recognizes the situation while he caught
him clips runs up five and y'all what a
block right there but then a five a
again blue gotten out to game alright to
rock it out full run back it's gonna
swap characters what's he feeling right
now is he feeling that meanest up it
could it could just be a stage change it
definitely there's absolutely oh we're
in character select right now are we
getting a swamp I'm turning around my
chair just to take a look oh not again
he showed you the button change the bus
okay the very good day Yoshi
Margy magic baby let's go Nabu Nabu all
right we're heading into game three
right now blue goddess up to oh but now
with a character change are we gonna see
the tides turn let's get it going
that's correct
today I'll be careful but he doesn't
stand up so he doesn't have to deal with
the light poles are very close here we
go the mix-up and there it is the spear
low arbitration the wires and feel
himself again was extremely close brown
but blue got able to flush it out
reversal eyes will connect what series
what we get this time okay just go
straight for fire
oh it's gonna actually knock us down and
leave ya alright good pressure out now
an absolute in right now
I'm just chillin on the ground but oh he
blocks like flash on a hot even planks
don't need any morning's doin far David
nice yes I do Oh what is that right
there yep there you go rock of getting
on the board here put that boy skull but
he displeased with his ankles right
there it's broken absolutely a nightly
to the bangle and eye for an eye that's
right well hey action I like it trying
to hit about this a mile caught him out
of the unblockable he actually got a
back turn right there mix-up opportunity
here
red guard page did not get up into it he
stood up into it may be expecting a wall
whatever the case may be he ended up
getting a live give the spin
you're amazing Vegas he was put in the
roulette wheel will here we go blue God
I got massive lazy up to me oh we guess
it doesn't matter where you tell four to
five and look at the life lead he is
right now the perfect has ended he's
gonna be able to knock down heroes able
to get me out not a lot of health 9k put
his hands on an ugly dance get five
eight unfortunately for low low and now
set point here from move on there is two
parts the low low oh yeah he was trying
to jump on top of it to be able to
probably be bleeding
I stole cars coming out of Newsline
here's gonna be isotonic our damage 6b
is gonna catch it well all right here we
go
don't you work it straight [ __ ] oh what
a total weren't right they're getting
the lethal hit because of it yeah he
tried to kid right in his back Oh got
the mix up in his own however and
there's the bus a busser and that's
gonna do it blue gun with a very quick
3-0
there you go blue god advancing his way
to grand final incredible take even
victory over low low low low low
incredible incredible feeling ballon and
incredible matches incredible game and
such a wonderful human being you know
who's gonna win that oh okay it's two
out of three probably okay Oh one two
one one
Oh powerful oh yeah you've got the thing